tonight I'm joined by the leader of the
no campaign
better together Alistair Darling MP
welcome to you indeed Alistair Darling
heard the Prime Minister earlier this
evening making the case that
independence would mean a painful
divorce and that Scots would be much
better off staying with the Union yet
people have been writing in to us and
saying well actually Scotland is a poor
country food you know food bank queues
are growing that we've been together for
300 years and they haven't done that one
out of it what the first thing is that
Scotland can be a prosperous country
although I argue that it would be more
prosperous being by being part of the
United Kingdom there's a separate
argument about how fair Scotland is or
lead for that matter how fair the whole
of the United Kingdom is because a
dispute distribution of wealth and
assets of course is another matter and
you know here I might well disagree with
other politicians I think the the other
point that has to be made and I think
that the Prime Minister made it today is
that unlike a general election when you
can vote in the government and if you
don't like them in four or five years
time you can kick them out if we vote to
leave on Thursday there's no going back
but the question is if you're not doing
very well after three hundred and seven
years of Union why stick with it why not
try something new why not take that
gamble gamble it's precisely what we're
talking about gambling with our
children's future never mind our own
future
as I say to you there is a perfectly
good argument for saying that people
won't change in the way that wealth is
distributed in this country to make sure
that people on lower incomes get a
better chance to get on for themselves
and their families but my you know
before you can do that of course you've
got to make sure that you're generating
enough wealth in the first place and I'm
firmly convinced that if Scotland were
to go to alone we would not do as well
as if we were part of the United Kingdom
why is that well quite simply because if
you look at most Scottish firms and
businesses they sell far more to the
rest of the United Kingdom than they do
in Scotland and actually having that
bigger market of 60 million people
benefits us all far more than would be
the case if we had a boy
border a boundary a barrier between the
firms here and the customers down in
duty badly selling a stuff
yeah but of course people trade across
Europe and of course they trade across
the world
that the point is we don't have a single
market of the sort that we have within
the United Kingdom where you've got the
same currency where you've got the same
rules and regulations and financial
services where as you know a lot of the
banks and the pension companies have
been saying look if we vote to go our
separate ways we'll have to move
business out of Scotland will have to
move headquarters out of Scotland so the
advantage we have in the United Kingdom
today is that we have a single market
and you don't have that in Europe they
call it a single market but it's nothing
like it wouldn't be because you would
have a border a barrier between firms
here and firms and customers south of
the border you see that effect in the
United States between Canada and the
rest and the United States of America
well there's more trade with the
Canadian provinces there is that cross
into the United States so I believe that
putting up a barrier or a border would
be a huge impairment never mind my view
you will see that businesses large and
small are saying the same thing they
think this we bound for business
therefore it would be bad for jobs and
bad for the amount of money that we can
raise to pay for things like the Health
Service why is it taking so long to make
the positive case for the Union as you
know tonight in Trafalgar Square there's
a rally many expatriate Scots many
English people saying let's stick
together and here's Darren Green writing
in France saying there 60 million people
in Great Britain why is it we don't all
get to say this affects us not just the
five and a half million people in
Scotland look at the streets raising
three different questions there the
first one is it must be right that it's
up to people in Scott from to decide
whether or not we want to be part of the
United Kingdom I believe that a majority
will vote to stay in the United Kingdom
the second thing you asked about why is
it you know the big demonstration in
Trafalgar Square tonight it's just the
fact that there's been a there's been a
referendum campaign here running for two
and a half years it seems an awful long
time for those who live here but do any
come in the last couple of weeks a that
they're actually he likes ignited that
is not true he has been up several times
in the
a couple of years very good this is a
campaign that's been running for two and
a half years its intensity in Scotland
has stepped up dramatically even in the
last couple of months and it's not
surprising that if you live in England
Wales and Northern Ireland
you'd be slightly more detached from it
until fairly recently the first point
you ask me about is you know if you like
the optimistic the positive case for the
Union which I've been making since I
launched this campaign in June 2012 the
the emotional argument as you said in
your introduction 300 years of history
Scotland helped built the United Kingdom
our influence in the rest of the United
Kingdom has been you know far greater
than you might expect for a population
of 5 million but it's not just that it's
the opportunities the security that come
from being part of unique ninety Kingdom
most of us in Scotland are friends and
you should do this under EU rules which
meant that residents here and the people
who get them well that's the Scottish
government chose to do that yeah exactly
I mean would you prefer to come up with
a system whereby perhaps some of those
expatriates courts could have had what
so I find it galling that if you are an
EU national here you get a vote from my
country future whereas if somebody might
have moved down south for say five or
six years you don't however that's the
rules the Scottish government came up
with there's no point in me now
three days before people go to the polls
you know saying I think well I wish it
was different rules that David Cameron
when the Scottish government got elected
with it with a majority in 2011 they had
a mandate and if we'd said at the time
oh no you can't do this or that they
would have been screaming from the
rooftops the fact is they had that
that's that's the electorate but company
to come back to the central pointed
issue and that is we in Scotland have
got to decide in three days time whether
we build on what we've got no one is
arguing the present situation is perfect
of course it's not everybody wants
change and the choice actually is
between a stronger Scottish Parliament
the one that's just behind us just now
with more powers and their ability to
rate to raise money for things like the
Health Service but with the advantages
of staying within ninety Kingdom and
crucially not taking on any of the risks
to jobs to the funding of the Health
Service to you know the prices we'd pay
for those I mean there is this problem
that the No campaign is perceived as
having been
negative of focusing on fear what could
go wrong under Independence mean here's
where McKinley's sent in a question why
has the no campaign focused on fear and
not the positive team contributions of
each country we do we do both I mean I
said remember you've got what the
question in front of us the nationalist
government here is saying to people in
Scotland do you want Scott from to leave
the UK yes or no right so it's not
surprising when somebody comes to you
and puts before you a proposition to you
that they say is going to change your
life it's about like deciding whether
you live with somebody who you're going
to get married or you have a complete
career change paying for what wars or a
painful doors surely you ask yourself at
the very start am I prepared to take on
these risks and you know it's not- to
ask these things what is scary it's
three days before we go to vote we have
no idea what currency we'll be using we
have no idea what effect it will have on
headquarters because people are saying
they're going to have to move them that
is scary but there is a contradiction
there there on the one hand you say well
look there are all these things that
could go wrong and then on the other
hand you say because you are a patriot
but of course I'm quite sure Scotland
could go it alone I mean which is it's
not going to be a disaster if it's their
dependent is it going to go in a line
I've said on a number of occasions
Scotland like any other country can go
it alone if it chooses to do so I just
think we will have a better chance of
creating the jobs we have in the future
of making sure we've got the security to
be able to pay pensions in the future if
we stay within the United Kingdom you
know we we've we don't we have no reason
not to be proud of what we've done to be
proud of our identity indeed I would
argue that someone who is Scottish and
my identity is stronger by being
Scottish but being partly said they are
able to pay pensions I mean does that
mean that you think net Scotland gets a
good deal from the rest of the UK well
let me do I can do no better here than
refer you to what the Scottish finance
secretary John Swinney said a couple of
years ago he pointed out that our
population in Scotland was ageing faster
than it is in the rest of the knighted
Kingdom and he said at the moment the
costs of that are falling across the six
a population of 63 million whereas we
went it alone it would fall on the
shoulders of five million so yes the
United Kingdom at billion odd parts of
the United Kingdom at different times
benefit from those parts that are doing
well nationalists would also say that
Gotland on a per capita basis is
wealthier than other parts of the UK and
and and that it's got the oil and it
would actually be better itself yeah
yeah be careful because that will they
quote you GDP figures which includes a
lot of money that is actually
repatriated if you know like all money
to America and you mentioned oil oil has
been a really good deal for the whole of
the UK for the last what 40 odd years
however on any of you every barrel you
take out of the North Sea oil it
declined that you know there's less oil
left we know it's declining look at the
oil price today it is something like
ninety eight dollars a barrel it was a
hundred and thirteen when they published
a white paper only ten months ago so
that you know already and he'd last year
they lost the equivalent of everything
we spend in schools in just one year I
don't want to be so dependent on one
source of income for the tax money that
that Scott from would raise and that's
why I think you know the advantages of
being something bigger is that when
something goes wrong or where you've got
a big structural problem you it with
check with the working age population
and rising pension age surely it's
better that your pool and share
resources and that's that's how you know
that's how America works that's how
Canada works that's how we work in the
UK it doesn't work in the eurozone which
is the example that they're true you
know they would like to adopt will you
accept the result even if there's a look
demand votes democracy yes and you'd
accept the Nationalists only need to win
once by one vote and that's it Lord is
no going back so because we've seen in
other countries referendums being held
several times until they get the right
time quit you know that the the the only
encouraging thing from our last exchange
with Alex Salmond is we both agreed that
whatever the result come Friday morning
we accept it and that works both ways
because Trish Duffy is said to us
whatever the outcome we are going to be
left with a hugely divided population
how are you going to unite the people of
Scotland after the referendum all over
the result well that's right I'm afraid
that whilst this campaign may have
energized a lot of people in Scotland
aspects that have been deeply depressing
I mean how depressing was it when you
saw a march through the streets of
Glasgow yesterday with with posters of
journalists that were out of favour with
you know the Nationals yeah yeah but you
don't this is a totally alien to you
know
you know what we're used to in this
country you don't see demonstrations
with journalists have pictures being
accelerated yeah yeah but some people
find it deeply sinister and you know and
I think you know there's a lot of us in
Scotland who do are not prepared to be
bullied into something and you know you
know you ask people living here the
atmosphere here has been soured over the
last few weeks and we what whatever the
result there's good and because of some
of these habits I'm afraid
die hard whatever the result it is up to
everyone whether you're a politician or
whether you're not to make sure that as
a country we work together because
that's an all iron in your view is this
people going over the top on both sides
or is it predominantly one side what you
know we don't we don't have cyber nuts
who you know vilify people who stand who
say say the disagree with the government
you know we don't organize people you
know going around you know shouting
people down well we have had problems on
our side we deal with it immediately
because I think what you want in any
country is the people should feel free
to speak out speak their mind and they
should do it without any fear at all so
I hope come Friday morning that yes the
country will be divided and we need to
work on that however in the next three
days surely it's better we concentrate
on the massive issue this is the biggest
decision that we will take in our
lifetime but I mean do you think there
are supporters of the Union who frankly
have been afraid to speak out which yes
I have I mean I two years ago and I
started off people said to me look those
people were afraid to speak out and I
didn't believe them and then I started
talking to you know business after
business people in the artists arts
world and culture and they said sorry
I'm not prepared to do it because what
isn't the only good thing that's
happened the last 10 days actually when
the polls narrow as I always said they
did is it is galvanized a lot of people
who up until now have been reluctant to
say things and say this is so big I'm
not prepared to see my you know the
wrong way might think you've got a
silent majority there but you I think I
think there is a quiet majority in
Scotland who are going to say no thanks
by the time the polls close and Thursday
evening what about you know your own
position if Scotland votes for
independence what what happens today I
live in Scotland you know and I'm gonna
stay in Scotland you know you know I
like my country and I think yes the
politicians won't have a seat at West
Coast of course not because we would be
a foreign country would you think it was
representative office
here well I'm asked this every time I
appear and I'll give you the same answer
in the days following the referendum
I've got a big decision to make as to
whether or not I stand again whether I
do something completely different I
don't know at the moment I'm totally
focused or we've been under two and a
half year halt here I believe that we
will win on Thursday and everything I do
is directed towards that I mean the
reason why I ask you is you know this
very well he said it again the weekend
Alex Salmond says that if there is a
vote for independence he wants to work
with you he wants you and what comes to
you yeah I like salmon and teamwork are
not two things that you know most people
most of us who live here think go
together all of us in Scotland will
always do our best that doesn't mean
we're going to agree with it you know it
really is offensive from say he's team
Scotland the majority the quiet majority
we're team Scotland were all team
Scotland promised it's like one of the
things he said was that a yes vote
independence for Scotland could mean
having to pack a passport to visit your
friends and family is that really how
it's going to be people in England are
gonna have to pack a passport to come to
Scotland or from Scotland to go to
England well you would be going into a
foreign country that's the bit that
actually makes people you know sit up
and think do we really want to do this
because our relationship Scotland's
relationship to England Wales and
Northern Ireland would be the same as it
is to France or to germinate now whether
or not you're asking about border
control you know the nationalists
sometimes say look our immigration
policy is not going to change much at
all therefore you wouldn't have to have
any controls all all the times I say
look we'll be running a radically
different for example we have friendly
relations with Ireland you don't need a
passport to go to Ireland wouldn't the
equivalent really what do you even wear
here to Scotland be like that you know
what the last time I was in Dublin night
I took my passport with me in order to
get into the country you know sir that
was just a fact of life I wouldn't have
gone to the airplane if I didn't have
one I don't want to be in that position
I don't want to even to raise those
questions Lingus actually I think it was
it doesn't matter they all wanted a
passport technically you don't need one
when you pitch up at the border control
and Dublin Airport you certainly need
one you won't get in otherwise look the
the issue that we we've got to look at
is that the realities if you decide
that you want to be independent of the
rest of you in the UK you are creating
two separate countries I don't want any
of that because I don't think it's
necessary as I said to you in the first
part of the program most people in
Scotland I think want to have change
there but they can you can do that
within the United Kingdom with a
stronger Scottish panel without all the
risks and the inconveniences that would
come if we broke away the suspicion that
sometimes the No campaign is setting up
sort of unnecessary consequences for
example the latest proposals on
devolution that were outlined last week
full taxation powers to a Scottish
Parliament how come you can have a
currency union in those circumstances
yet you can't within two Polar's and it
wasn't was a big difference what you're
talking about is at the moment when the
Scottish Parliament was set up in 1997
it had the power to vary income tax by
three pence and it never actually used
it but had the power to do that it's
already got additional powers coming so
that from 2016 it's got to fix the
Scottish rate but that is within the the
United Kingdom a currency union is
something completely different that is
where you you know a country in the case
that you can I to Kingdom the the pound
sterling is backed by the Bank of
England behind that stands 63 million
tax payers if we leave the United
Kingdom we've left that framework that
that currency that bank which would then
belong to the rest of the UK to me to
make a currency union work you do you
don't have to imagine it you just have
to look and see you have never an
independence one would never have access
to the power to get a currency union to
work you need both sides to agree to it
that's you know that's what the eurozone
is struggling at at the moment and one
of the reasons the struggle it's
struggling is because to make it work
you have to be able to transfer money
between one part and another like they
can do in the United States for example
you can't do it in Europe which is why
you've got so much of southern Europe a
lot of southern Europe that is you know
virtually paralyzed because it doesn't
work now if dope both sides don't agree
a currency union is simply it isn't
going to happen the other thing that the
Nationalists are looking at their plan B
of you like apparently is to be like
Panama which as you know panama uses the
US dollar to make that work you've got
have a massive stockpile of cash to make
sure you don't run up it's worth it's
equivalent to about four thousand pounds
for every every
living in Scotland it's a massive amount
now I asked myself as somebody lives in
Scotland who wants to see this as a good
place to live to make sure we generate
enough money to pay for I think is
turbulence in Stirling would not be good
for the rest of the UK anyway so they
would want in our own interest the
government in London would it's odd for
the person who's creating the turbulence
by breaking up the UK to then complain
that nobody is sorting out the problems
he's then caused would have you look at
the currency union look it out from a
Scottish point of view it would be a bad
deal for Scotland I mean how can a
nationalist go into a currency union
that would mean that another government
would agree as tax in his spending on
that isn't that that's that's more like
serfdom than its read about this issue
of the health service question from
Stuart Henderson will the NHS be forced
to privatize in the future if there is a
no vote no it won't because the control
of the health service in Scotland is
100% devolved to the Scottish Government
the only one who can privatize the
health service in Scotland is the First
Minister not the Prime Minister and
indeed in their manifesto in 2011 the
Nationalists boasted about the fact
nobody could interfere on the spending
it was another interesting fact English
health spending has been going up in
real terms by about 3% in Scotland it
hasn't where does that where does the
blame for that work right there in the
Scottish Parliament it's a Scottish
government that has chosen not to do
that nobody else I think there is quite
a lot of skepticism about whether this
Divo max package could ever be delivered
given that it would be the Westminster
Parliament and the House and Lords that
would have to pass it but with
devolution or indeed with independence
while they're still Scottish MPs at
Westminster would they lose the right
immediately to vote on English matters
until such time as the United Kingdom
was dissolved by an act of Parliament it
continues to exist so that you know do
you think it would still be MPs but they
would have to respect I think the result
because presumably under that that's
what you're speculating on and it is
only speculation is that we would what
about the devolution why it was gods
have these extra powers to decide on
their future when the English don't have
what look there's two issues yet firstly
you said you know in relation to
the additional powers that we're putting
forward are you sure it's going to
happen people said exactly the same
before 1997 where they say you'll never
get a Scottish Parliament you'll never
get it through the House of Lords it'll
never be agreed in the House of Commons
well it was and it's been established
now for 15 15 years there's a broader
question which I think you touch on and
that is if you have a Scottish
Parliament with more powers then the
question arises should Wales for example
have more powers and as you know the
first minister of Wales was up here last
week and he was making precisely that
point I think there's also an issue
which obviously is not the subject of
this referendum and that is that I think
the imbalance economic imbalance between
the the big English cities outside we
had many occasions where Welsh and
Scottish MPs between them have actually
commanded the majority on decisions
affecting England yes we're the other
way too and yeah yeah look I think that
the great difficulty is and successive
governments have looked at this you know
for the last 40 years as how can you
have two classes of MPs and if people
have really come to the view that it
doesn't really work which you're right
that you know I have no problem in
saying that the structure of the United
Kingdom the Constitution that needs to
move on every known again for a long
time it didn't move on and you know
that's to adapt to my position as the
yes campaign an awful lot of question
marks about the UK no no that I'm
talking about the arrangements within
the United Kingdom like yes of course
the adapt but there's not a good idea
for smashing the whole thing okay all
right is the better together
get-out-the-vote operation as effective
as the yes campaign yes it is you know
we have a very big organization
throughout the country we've contacted
tens of thousands of people even in the
last couple of weeks so I'm very
confident we'll get the vote out and I'm
very confident that we'll win on
Thursday